a couple of hours ago today the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt just announced
the new Autumn statement and a lot of it
was about property investment and oh my
goodness it's blowing my mind I've spent
the last few hours since the statement
researching it watching it over again
and again reading the government website
the print and I'm absolutely excited to
announce exactly what the new statement
is and share with you how this is going
to affect you as a property investor
there's five things five huge things
that are specifically going to affect
you as a property investor the first
thing is permitted development rights if
you don't know what permitted
development rights is they brought this
in in 2008 initially and they said
there's certain things that you can do
without having to get planning
permission and one of those things was
they said that you could turn a house
into a HMO without getting planning
permission as a result of that loads of
people did what got rich with permitted
development they turned houses
into hmos they got a higher rent and
then with that higher rent they got rich
and then the houses are you the hmos
pushed the house up in value and it was
absolutely incredible well guess what's
just happened today November 22nd
20123 they've done the same thing again
but not for hmos for Flats they've just
said that you can turn a house into
Flats without getting planning
permission using the same permitted
development rights which
means that now you see a house for
£100,000 you can buy that house you're
going to be able to buy that house and
turn it into two Flats without planning
permission why is that absolutely
incredible as an entrepreneur that wants
to make money in property well because
two houses or two properties two
properties clearly is more valuable than
one so if you can turn one house into
two properties without getting planning
permission well that's going to mean
number one that you've got two lots of
rent coming in from one property number
two you've just pushed the value of that
property up and you can do it without
getting planning permission so that
alone has given me an early Christmas
present that alone has made me so happy
so I wanted to share that with you on
YouTube but there's other stuff that
they're saying number secondly saying
that you can um you can buy a house with
a 5%
deposit 5% deposit maybe you didn't hear
this when they announced it the first
time around okay because this was
announced a little while back and so
many people as a result have been buying
houses with 5% deposit now this is
limited it's got to be your house that
you're buying to live in and also you do
have to be earning the correct amount of
income to be able to get the mortgage so
this isn't for everybody but they've
just said the chance has just said you
can they're going to extend this offer
for at least another 18 months which
means
that right now
2023 coming into 2024 the opportunities
are insane this is not like oh it might
potentially come in no it's already in
you can optimize this right now start
buying properties and doing this right
now they're also increasing rents for
Council houses so if you've got DSS
tenants from uh local housing
authorities living in your Properties or
maybe you haven't but maybe you were
thinking man I want to buy some houses
but you know who am I going to rent it
to If you're looking in cheap areas well
you can rent it to council tenants and
they're about to put the rents up that's
not been that's not happened since 20120
for 3 years so they're about to put the
rents up so houses are dropping at the
moment house prices are dropping but
rents are going up planning permissions
getting
easier and and and and and the yields
are higher
another thing is this very interesting
the counselor just did his um the
councelor just did his
speech and it's all over the
news all over the news but guess what
the BBC aren't saying and Sky News
aren't saying and all the channels
aren't reporting on they're not
reporting on any other the stuff I'm
saying they're talking about they're
talking about minimum wagees just gone
up by a pound and everyone's like oh
exciting minimum wage has gone up isn't
that incredible now instead of getting
paid 10 an hour and get paid £1 an hour
that's how I'm going to get rich that's
not how you're going to get rich minimum
wage just went up by maybe 10% but guess
what inflation has gone up by
30% since lockdown so if you're excited
about getting paid extra pound an
hour this is what this is what the news
is talking about the news is talking
about pensions oh pensions have just
gone up by
88.5% isn't that amazing let's all stay
in our job jobs and get paid an extra
pound and invest into our pension which
is now not going to give us23 a week
when we're 69 years old it's going to
give us £216 a
week what tax oh we can we're going to
pay um a titly bit less tax no you're
not if you actually read it in full
you're going to end up probably paying
more tax but what's happening is the
media are talking to the employees the
mainstream news the media they're all
talking to you as if you are an employee
not an entrepreneur I'm speaking to you
as an entrepreneur and the interesting
thing is why aren't the media talking
about the fact that I seen it once the
biggest thing that was said which is you
can turn a house into Apartments without
planning permission in my opinion that's
the biggest thing that Jeremy Hunt said
today not mentioned it I couldn't find
it in the newspapers BBC didn't mention
it they two talking about minimum wage
has gone up by a pound why why are they
not talking about that why the the the
people that make the rules up catch this
the people that make the rules are the
people that make money in property so
there's all these incredible things like
um benefit tenants uh rent going up
permitting development turning houses
into Flats they're talking about
speeding up the process to buy and sell
houses they they're massively relaxing
planning laws just across the board
especially for excuse me especially for
property developers in fact at the
moment getting planning permission has
been a bit difficult but they're saying
that moving forward getting planning
permission is going to be much quicker
and they're going to give you planning
permission more easily right so all this
massive stuff that's going to make
property investors and property
developers millions and millions of
pounds Hush Hush not being talked about
you can only find that if you go into
the government website you know where to
look and you read hundreds of pages okay
amongst all this nonsense about not
nonsense I mean listen I'm pleased about
minimum wage going up I think it's a
good thing but that's if that's exciting
you if you're excited by getting an
extra pound an
hour then I don't know what to say
you're subscribed to the wrong Channel
cuz I'm excited about being able to turn
houses into Flats without getting
planning permission I'm now thinking man
I can buy buy a house for 100 grand
spend 10 grand reconfiguring things
around to get permitted developments now
I've pushed the value of the property up
but on top of that I've now got two lots
of tenants which is going to mean that I
can get a lot more rent but on top of
that maybe I could rent them out as
furnished service
departments oh man maybe I can buy a
small house for 100 grand maybe I can
rent each property out per night for
£100 a night compete with the hotels but
I got two apartments1 a night per
apartment would be
£3,000 a month each apartment which
would be six grand I'm I'm thinking how
can I make six grand a month from one
small £100,000 house and then how can I
increase the value of the house maybe
refinance it and get my 100 Grand back
with with with these with these new
potential rules that are coming in how
can I do that I'm not thinking about a
pound a pound an hour extra when it's
not going to make me any richer cuz the
cost of living is gone up by £3 and now
you've got an extra pound oo wonderful
I'm not thinking about my 88.5%
increased on my pension when the average
pension is around £200 a week 2 468
about 800 a month so you work for 40
years after going to University after
spending 40 Grand going to University to
get a degree you then get a job and work
40 years and work 40 hours a week to
them retire at 69 years old on2 200 a
week2 200 a week ain't enough to live
don't get excited by the smoke and
mirror distractions and nonsense on the
BBC read it properly I'm going to leave
a link as well by the way to Jeremy
Hunt's full speech I'm going to give you
the government um website direct link
where you can see exactly what's coming
in and listen the cynic the cynic and me
might be thinking about um you know oh
well maybe they're just saying this cuz
the elections coming up you know blah
blah blah yeah of course but not just
conservative but labor I don't really
care who gets in cuz conservative and
labor are saying the same thing they're
both going to make it a lot easier for
property developers and property
investors to get rich so there's so many
cool things happening and all this
scaremongering from the beginning of
2023 about tenant scrapping tenant
eviction bans did it happen no they
reversed it of course they did EPC
changes oh he everyone's said everyone
scared did they actually bring it in no
of course they didn't they reversed it
so pay attention to what's happening get
rich follow me because I'll tell you
what's actually being said and what's
actually going on also in during
Christmas in December that's when you
need to get real good at finding deals
that's when you need to get real good so
if you want to spend a day with me
shadowing me and watching me on my
computer finding deals and showing you
how to do it I'm going to be putting a
full
one day program where you can watch me
finding deals ask me questions pick my
brain obviously limited spaces you know
it wouldn't work if there was a thousand
people there be limited spaces um and if
you want to do that tickets
are1 one pound okay so come spend a day
with me start finding property deals I
want you to win I want you to be rich I
want to equal the playing field and see
ordinary folks becoming financially free
and then not having to get excited about
making a one pound per hour extra bonus
I want you to be excited about six grand
a month from one property and pushing
the value up and then refinancing it
permitted development like so I'm going
to be I'm going to be finding lease
option agreements commercial to
residential deals land opportunities
going through the entire process and
even if you haven't got the money to buy
even if you have got 5% deposit even if
you got not the money to buy a property
at all and you want to buy an investment
don't matter you find the deal you can
find the investor okay I myself have set
up my own Finance Company where I'm
investing millions of pounds into my
students deals so this is the time to be
excited Christmas is coming and
Christmas has come early for me and it
has for you too cuz I'm going to leave a
link in the description where you can
come spend the day with me for just one
pound no catch one pound get booked on
do it now spaces are going to sell out
I'm going to be in Birmingham I'm going
to be up north I think Manchester
Bradford Area I'm going to be in London
twice so grab your ticket I'll see you
there God bless